Binh nào, đi chơi về tờ đi, ở biệt hổ chỗ này hay lắm, cực kỳ thu vịt luôn, chỗ nào vậy.
Đi dổ sẽ nhất, đi nha, tinh.
Hải đứa không biết bơi, tịch lối không được ra cần cu vực bởi áo chơi nghe, quý hiểm lắm.
Và chúng trọng giữa rồi, à.
Mà sẽ cần cu vực chân chật, tắm sống, sống, sống, áo chữ sử dạm sát của người lớn,
và đặc biệt là sọ các em chứ được chẳng bị ký đặc bơi lỗi.
Để phóng vừa muy cơ đối nức, chả em cần trực lối chánh xa, hính đời quyền gì sống, bổ, áo sống.
Ký tham gia ra ra thông đường tuy, phải mặt áo phau, và hãy chụi đậm xin bố mẹ cho đi học bơi đây mùa hài này nhé.
Đi nhớ, khi thấy bản bị đối nức, chó không biết mời tự đối không được dạy xuống kí.
Thầy vào đó, chó hãy hồn hắn thật to quận người lớn, tìm một kênh ký dài vọng đếm bất lối như cân nhợ,
phau xuống cho bạn mắm vào.
Chởi với bình á, chào có sao không?
Nát dạng rồi, nó không nghe lời đả, chở xin lỗi bà.
Bịt lỗi và sử dụi mới là cộng bán hoàn.
Thái luôn nhớ, chẳng bị ký đặc bơi lỗi cho chánh ngày hôm nay để phòng người đối nức.
Hí cần trở giúp, hãy an nước, chú sẽ có mặt.
Hãy cùng vlu nó chắc bệnh ghi năng, ngày hôm nay.